i want to thank everyone for turning out
to see this assessing and mitigating
unfairness and ai systems workshop by
manoj nandi
i appreciate you having here and
hopefully everyone's having a good time
with phi data so far
manoj is a data scientist at microsoft
where he contributes to the fair learn
library he is interested in
understanding the challenges data
scientists face when incorporating
fairness practices into their workflow
um so that is a perfect setup for this
workshop and uh we appreciate you having
uh presenting here and i'm happy to hand
it over thank you thank you
so hey everyone
thank you for coming to this workshop
assessing and mitigating unfairness in
ai systems my name is minaj anandi i am
a data scientist at microsoft research
new york city
and how this workshop will go is that in
the first
hour of this workshop we'll be going
through a tutorial of how do we
assess and mitigate unfairness in a
machine learning model um using a
library called fair learn and the second
half of this workshop um my cohost
presenter michael madeo will host
organize a panel with three industry
practitioners and they will talk about
best practices
and techniques for implementing fairness
into your work
so why fairness
well if you've seen any news articles in
the past decade you've seen plenty of
stories like we are living in the age of
a.i we're living in this era of big data
at the same time
you've also seen stories about how
ai systems
have gone wrong you've seen stories
about
amazon having to scrape this
resume streaming tool because it was
found to discriminate against women
you've seen stories about google's uh
translate um gendering uh translations
from non-gendered languages to gendered
languages
and
plenty of other stories of similar
nature and there's also been books on
this topic we've also have documentaries
on netflix now talking about different
ways that ai systems can perpetuate
inequality and harm marginalized
populations
so this topic fairness and ai systems is
this emerging interdisciplinary field of
research and practice that aims to help
data scientists understand and assess
some of the negative impacts that ai
systems can have on society and the
world at large
and so in the first part of this
workshop we'll be walking through this
tutorial on the process of associating
and mitigating a fairness related harms
in a trained machine learning model in
this context of this u.s healthcare
system using the library fair learn so
what is fair learning you might ask
well fairlearn is an open source
community driven project that aims to
help data scientists improve the
fairness of their machine learning
models
we include things such as techniques and
metrics for quantifying um fairness
related harms in fairness metrics we
also provide algorithms for allowing
data scientists to mitigate on uh
unfairness they find in their trained
machine learning models
and we also provide tools for allowing
data scientists to visualize and
visualize and plot any sources of
unfairness or disparities they want to
present to stakeholders
in addition we're also interested in
creating educational resources
that cover not only the technical
aspects of fairness mitigation but also
some of the sociological practices and
concepts of fairness
fairlearn was started at in 2018 out of
microsoft research in new york city
however earlier this year we have
adopted a neutral governance structure
and since then it's completely community
driven
and one of the goal goals of the fair
learn project is that we want to build
this community of practitioners
who want to understand
like what data scientists need in order
to incorporate fairness best practices
into their work
so here's just a
python imports for the
tutorial later on i'm going to skip over
that briefly
so now let's talk a bit about fairness
and ai systems
now if you've heard anything about
fairness and ai systems you've probably
heard this term bias you've heard about
an algorithm being biased
uh or you've also heard this concept of
like de-biasing algorithms
however
for this tutorial i want to avoid using
that term bias
main reason is that the term bias is
very ambiguous in many cases
and can mean different things to
different communities for example in a
statistical community bias means
something completely different than what
it means in the sociological sense
instead i want to focus the conversation
around impact i want to censor the
conversation on those who are harmed by
these systems
rather than centering the conversation
on the ai systems themselves
and since we'll be disc focusing on the
harms to the people who are affected by
these systems we sort of need a
framework or language to discuss these
types of harms
so
we
have
three major types of fairness related
harms i want to talk about and one key
thing here is that these three types of
fairness
these three types of fairness related
harms are not the only three types of
fairness really harms and there are
plenty of more but these are the three
most common ones we see in
practice
the first is an allocation heart so an
allocation harm occurs when an ai system
allocates resources or opportunities in
a way that negatively impact people's
lives for example there was a story
about two years ago when apple credit
card first launched that many people
noticed that
men got much higher credit limits
compared to women and users could be a
married couple about um applying for
this credit card and they noticed that
when the husband applied for the credit
card they would get a much higher credit
limit compared to the wife
and so in this case this ai system is
unfairly allocating this resource of
credit limit uh in a way that
discriminates against women
next are quality of service types harms
so quality of service harms occur when
an ai system performs worse for one
group compared to another group even
when no opportunities are withheld
and quality service harms are very
common in these ai as a service system
so this is like um
face detection and speech text
translations these deep learning
problems that i like to call them and so
one famous example of a quality service
type charm is the gender shape project
so in 2018 uh mit researcher joy
bolawini
showed that these commercially available
base texture systems out of microsoft
ibm and face plus plus
they achieved a significantly higher
error rate on detecting the faces of
darker skinned females compared to the
faces of lighter skinned males in some
cases this
performance gap could be as large as 33
33 higher error for the darker skinned
women as it was for the lighter skinned
men and so this case this space
detection system isn't really allocating
a resource it's not deciding who gets a
job or not it's not deciding who gets a
credit loan or not but we are seeing
that this performing significantly worse
for one group of people compared to
someone else
and finally representation harms
and so representation harms occur when
an ai system stereotypes demeans or
promotes
an otherwise harmful antagonistic
representation of users
when google's photos first launched in
2015 there was a major scandal where a
group of black teens took a selfie at a
graduation party and google photos
automatically tag that selfie as
gorillas
and so this is really bad not only just
because it is a misclassification
but it is a misclassification in a way
that promotes an antagonistic stereotype
against
black individuals within western
countries
and one key thing about these types of
ferocious harms is that these are not
one of these are not the exhaustive list
of fairness related harms as i mentioned
bob but an ai system can also exhibit
multiple types of fairness related harms
the same ai system can produce both
quality of service harms as well as
resource allocation harms it can produce
quality of service harms and a
representation arms as well
and so now let's jump into the scenario
that we'll be talking about
there is one question from the audience
which is whether you will be sharing the
link to the to this notebook
yes and so i can share a link to this
notebook in the slack channel uh after
this workshop uh so i believe there is
an assessing and mitigate uh mitigating
unfairness slack channel
uh for the um and you i'll be sharing a
link to this notebook afterwards
yes
any other questions
[Music]
okay
now let's get into this uh scenario that
we want to work through for the rest of
this tutorial and so the scenario that
we're going to
work through sort of builds upon
previous research that's highlighted
racial disparities in how health care
resources are allocated in the united
states this paper obermeyer at all
written 2019 showed that we tend to
allocate um healthcare resources and
communities um proportional to health
healthcare costs and as a result this
tends to prioritize or over allocate
resources to predominate white
communities
motivated by that work this tutorial
will be thinking about building an
automated system for recommending
patients to this high risk care
management program
and the idea here is that you can think
about we're doc we're a data scientist
in a hospital and we've been tasked with
this uh building this classification
tool we sort of want to identify
patients who would benefit most from
this specialized care management program
and one key thing about this is that in
practice if we were to build a real
system like this we'd probably be using
a lot of large data sets
covering a wide variety of diagnosis
diagnosis and medical treatments however
for this context of this tutorial we'll
be working with this publicly available
clinical data set
uh that focuses only on diabetic
patients produced in this paper
strategol in 2014.
so what we'll be working with we'll be
working with a clinical data set of
hospital re-emissions
over a 10-year period from 1998 to 2008
for diabetic patients across 130
different hospitals in the united states
each record represents a hospital
admission record for a patient diagnosed
with diagnosed with diabetes and their
stay lasted between 1 to 14 days
the features in this data set
um
artists are pertaining to the the
hospital admission encounter and this
includes things such as the demographic
information stuff patient
uh medical diagnoses any diabetic
medication and then also past medical
history within the previous year so that
they have hospital visits in the
previous year
before this encounter as well as payer
information such as did they pay with
medicare medicaid or do they pay with
private health care insurance
and we also have information about
whether the patient was readmitted after
release
and did that re-emission occur within 30
days of release
and now we the data scientists
we've been tasked with developing a
classification model which decides
whether the patient should be successful
suggested in uh to a
should be suggested to enroll in this
specialized high risk care management
program
the positive prediction of this model
means that yes we recommend that patient
into a care management program
and so here this is the task we've been
given so now that's how we formalize
this task into a machine learning
problem
one thing we'll think about is what is
our label
so a hospital re-emission within 30 days
can be viewed as a proxy that the
patient needed more assistance at
release time what this means is the
patient was discharged from the hospital
but within three days they had to come
back to the hospital and this could mean
that what this probably means is that
the patient was probably not given the
adequate level of care the first time
they were not given appropriate level
care their first visit they were
released from the hospital but then they
had to come back because their symptoms
were not properly treated
and so this is the label that we want to
predict now the thing about this being
is proxy is not a perfect proxy for who
would be best benefit from this program
a patient for example could be released
from the hospital and come back to the
hospital in 30 days for a completely
different um emergency or situation
maybe a car crash for example
and because of class and balance we'll
be measuring the performance of our
machine learning model via balance
accuracy
another thing that we want to keep in
mind when
evaluating the performance of any
machine learning model on this task is
how many patients are recommended for
this care management program
and this is a metric that we will refer
to as the selection rate which is just
the percentages of positive labels that
the model outputs
and once again if we were building a
system like this in the real world we'd
ideally be working with medical experts
and other healthcare professionals who
would be very closely involved with both
the design of this machine learning
model but then also how this model is
used and deployed
now since we want to talk about the
fairness considerations
here's the type of fairness
considerations we as a data scientist
should be thinking about
first we want to think about like which
groups do we expect to be most
proportionately
negatively impacted by this model
well if we view the
academic literature on healthcare in the
united states there's a lot of prior
work that suggests groups with different
race drill and ethnic groups
um are differentially treated through
the u.s health care system
and what are the harms here
the key harms here are allocation harms
in particular the false negative in this
case we don't recommend someone to the
high risk care management program who
will then be admitted to readmitted to
the hospital and the way you can think
about this is that we don't recommend
this to program someone to this care
risk care match program that would have
greatly benefited from it
and the final question is how do we
measure those harms
now when we talked about the task at
hand so now when we're building any sort
of ai or machine learning system there
are two critical decisions that we
always are making one which is
how we define the machine learning task
and secondly what data set do we use to
train our models
and in practice these choices are often
intertwined because the data set we
choose is more so a convenience data set
it's sort of a data set that's easily or
readily available to us without much
difficulty
and that can lead us to choosing a
specific type of label and performance
metric and that is the case here in our
scenario where we chose a publicly
available data set that may or may not
be the best data set
possible if we wanted to build a real
system like this
and so in this section of this tutorial
we're going to load the data set and
then we're going to examine and explore
the data set for a variety of issues in
particular with a focus on ideas about
fairness and possible fairness related
issues that might arise downstream
we'll pay close attention to the sample
sizes of our different demographic
groups and then the appropriateness of
our choice of label with readmission
within 30 days
and if we're
doing this in practice one thing we'd
want to do is actually systematically
document our findings of the data set
through some sort of practice such as
the data sheet practice
by documenting our understanding of the
data set we can communicate any concerns
we have about the data and highlight
issues that may arise during the model
training process the model evaluation
process or the model deployment process
and in addition when we're talking about
data set ferris one thing we might also
want to think about
is whether the data was collected in a
uh whether that data set was collected
in an um manner that respects the
autonomy of individuals
so first thing we're going to do is
we're going to load the data set
and look at some of the columns in it
so we've looked at we've loaded the data
set let's take a look at some of the
columns here so we have things such as
columns such as race we have gender we
have age
and then we also have information about
how long they spent in the hospital
the number of lab procedures they had
met information about diabetes and also
their past history
as well as whether they were readmitted
to the hospital and in particular
whether they're readmitted within 30
days
and this is a table that gives us a
brief summary of all that information
things we see is that
we here we have demographic features we
have insurance information and most
importantly we have that readmission
information
and this shows like all the categor uh
uh shows all the categorical information
uh so we can see here for race we have
uh six different racial groups such as
caucasian african-american unknown
hispanic other and asian gender we have
female male unknown and valid
and so we're going to mark our
categorical variables
and now the first thing we want to talk
about when we're talking about uh
fairness it's sort of this idea of group
sample sizes and from the perspective of
fairness assessment uh sample sizes are
very important for two important reasons
one is sort of modeled um
one is for uh one important implication
is sort of assessment of unfairness in
your machine learning model
because we have a smaller number of data
points for certain groups it might be
higher harder to assess the true measure
of disparity or unfairness for that a
particular group because we tend to have
more uncertainty or error bars in our
estimate
second is in the model training process
for demographic groups that we have
fewer number of training points in our
model that may uh may mean our model may
fail to appropriately capture any data
patterns specific to that smaller group
thus meaning that the predictive
performance of our model on those
underrepresented groups could be much
worse so now let's examine the sample
size according to race
so we can see here
that
in our data set that the data set is
disproportionately
overly represented by individuals
labeled as caucasian
about 75 of the data is labeled as
caucasian the next largest group is
african american at about 19
and the remaining racial uh racial
categories including unknown compose
only about six percent of the data
next let's explore the uh data set
composition by gender
and we see here that in this case the
individuals on our data set are
effectively labeled as in gender in a
binary sense that about 54 of the
individuals in the data are labeled as
women and
46 percent individuals in our data set
are labeled as uh male and they're only
about three they're only three samples
in this data set annotated with this uh
gender label of unknown invalid
and so
at this point we come to a very
important decision which is how do we
address these smaller group size group
sizes
and when we lack
then when our data lacks coverage of
certain groups it may mean that we might
not be able to reliably assess any sort
of fairness related harm for those
groups and then there are three
interventions which can be carried out
um that reasons carry out
we don't necessarily have to pick one
strategy we can pick multiple of them
one is going and collecting more data we
can go out and collect more data for
groups with fewer samples however in
certain cases that may not be
feasible or physically possible in a
reasonable amount of time
next is that we could bucket or merge
some of these groups together
and finally we could just drop these
groups that we have too few data points
for
and the choice of which strategy we
choose
really depends on our existing
understanding of like which groups do we
believe to be at the greatest risk of
harm
in particular uh pooling or bucketing
smaller groups together could mat with
widely different risks could mass the
extent of harms and we generally caution
against dropping small groups as this
leads to a representational harm of
erasure
if any groups are immersed or dropped
these decisions should be documented or
annotated somewhere either in a docume
data sheets or some other
documentation process
in our case we will merge the three
smallest racial groups asian hispanic
and other and this follows the work done
in the original paper by strathcl but we
will retain access these groups for
auxiliary assessments
and next we will drop the gender group
unknown and valid because this sample
size of three is too small for us to
make any meaningful fairness assessment
next is label imbalance and so with the
idea of label mouse we want to care
about the frequency of our predictive
label especially as it correlates
overall but then also by our different
uh demographic groups of interest
and
label and balance is very important in
the machine learning process because in
certain cases certain classification
algorithms and performance measures
might not work well with data sets with
extreme class and balance
in binary classification setting our
ability to draw evaluate errors often
driven by the size of the smaller of the
two classes and so once again
um
and then also label and balance may
exacerbate problems uh when we talk
about the fair um we talk about fairness
assessment and we'll uh for smaller
groups sample sizes
so now let's check out our label
distribution um in the data set look at
how many percent of data sets are
labeled as positive and how many are
labeled as negatives
and so we see here that within our data
set with our label of re-emit within 30
days about 89 of the data is labeled as
zero that means about 89 of patients are
not readmitted within 30 days on the
other hand the
percentage of patients who are remitted
within 30 days is only about 11
so only about 10 or 11 of the patients
are remitted within 30 days
since there are fewer positive examples
we expect that to have much larger
uncertainty or error bars in our
estimates of the false negative rate
compared to the false positive rate this
means there will be larger differences
between our training false negative rate
and test false negative rate even if
there's no overfitting simply because of
the small sample sizes
the our performance metric of interest
the balance uh error rate or balanced
accuracy is the average of the false
positive rate and the false negative
rate
because this um this metric is robust to
different frequencies of positive and
negatives however since half the metric
is contributed by the false negative
rate we expect the uncertainty
quantification of the balanced error
rates to behave similar to the
uncertainty of the false negative rate
now let's examine the label frequency uh
by race
and so what we see here is that for the
rate of emission of um the rate of 30
day readmission
across our different racial groups is
about the same for african american and
caucasian groups
but this appears to be smaller for the
other and unknown racial categories
and so what this means is if we're using
30-day readmission as our proxy for who
should be recommended for um this
high-risk care management program then
these
individuals labeled as this other or
unknown racial group will be less likely
to receive this just due to a lower base
rate
and this is also amplified by the fact
that because we have a smaller number of
data points for these groups that we
expect to see more uncertainty around
this estimate
now let's get into the process of
training our initial model
so when we want to train our initial
classification model to predict our
target variable re-emission over 30 days
we want to ask ourselves what kind of
model do we want to train do we want to
train a neural network do you want to
train a random force or do you want to
train a logistic regression
and when you're deciding what kind of
model we want to build there's lots of
considerations we wanted to take account
and we're going to highlight two one is
interpretability so interpretability is
very closely linked to this idea of
fairness and there might be and there
are very reason of various reasons why
interpretable models are very important
um for apprentice is that allows us to
discover various issues that were not
discovered by the fairness team it
allows external stakeholders or domain
experts to come in and be able to
examine our models and our model's
behavior and performance identify
issues that the data science team may
not have the domain knowledge to
understand
it provides a path for recourse for
those who are affected by the model so
individuals who are not um
not recommended for this program we can
use this interpretability to basically
understand what they need to be
different about them in order to be
recommended to this care management
program
and also provides a face validity check
by domaine express to make sure that the
models make sense that at the face value
the model's making predictions on
variables or features that a domain
expert would consider important
and the next thing is sort of model
expressiveness how well can the model
separate positive examples from negative
examples
and how well can do so on the available
data set
and can it do so across all our
different demographic groups or does it
need to trade off performance for one
group on another
in addition there are other types of
considerations we want to think about uh
when we decide with model one to use
such as training time which is how long
does it take to train a model and this
could impact our ability to reiterate or
update the model familiarity with the
models so this could affect our ability
to fine-tune our debugger model if we
choose a model that we are not very
familiar with and finally one thing we
want to think about is the carbon
footprint of training the model so how
much energy or computation is used to
train that particular model and this
impacts both the earth's climate
directly and indirectly by normalizing
unnecessarily heavier worker lows so at
this point we've come to a decision of
like what kind of model we want to use
and we're going to go with a logistic
regression and our reasoning is false
well interpretability well logistic
regressions uh over a small number of
variables such as ones here are very
interpretable
in the sense that's much easier for a
stakeholder to understand what's going
on behind the scenes compared to say a
random forest where an external
stakeholder may not be able to
understand what the model is doing
one concern might be model
expressiveness that linear regression
predictions might be too simple
uh compared to more complex models such
as a random forest or a neural network
however a previous work by stractectol
um really they used the logistic
regression model and they were able to
predict readmission rates and this sort
of gives us some evidence that maybe a
logistic regression would be good enough
for this uh
predicting this label
and so now let's prepare our data set
and our training and test data set
and so as we mentioned our test
definition our target variable is
re-emission within 30 days and for the
purpose of this fairness assessment
we're going to focus on race
and so we're going to separate out our
target label y as the re-emission within
30 days and our sensitive feature
as
race
now we're going to build our training uh
we're going to build our featured data
set and
encode dummy variables for our
categorical features
and we can take a sense of take a view
of what this looks like now
and so this is what the data set we'll
be working with looks like
and now we want to split our data set
into a training and test portion the
test portion will be used to evaluate
our performance metric for balance a
balanced accuracy but we'll also use it
for the fairness assessment and for the
purposes of this uh
tutorial we'll be doing a split that's
half and half
to uh 5050 to ensure that we have enough
data points in the test data set that we
can have do a proper fairness assessment
and we can capture meaningful sample
sizes for our fairness assessment and
test data set
so we establish a random seed we do our
training test split and the data set
will be 50 50 into
training and test status uh
data set training and test labels but
also training tests are sensitive
features
and so our performance metric for this
is balance accuracy and and for the
purposes of training but not for
evaluation we will re-sample the data
set so it has the same number of
positive negative examples
uh what we'll be doing is we'll be down
sampling the data set
says that we remove uh such that the
number of positive examples and the
number of negative samples is the same
and so we'll be down summing the number
of negatives
and what this means is that this might
be a challenge for more complex machine
learning models because we'll now be
creating a training data set with a
fewer number of points and thus it might
affect the model's ability to converge
and so now we're going to resample our
training data set and now let's train
our machine learning model and so first
thing we're going to do is um build a
logistic regression model
and
fit it to the training data set
and now we can compute the model's
performance
and we see that the balance accuracy
score of our model is about 60
and with an uh aoc of 0.63 and so what
this means is that this is a
decently fit model
but maybe might not be
uh but this is also a very hard
classification task like we have an
accuracy of a balance accuracy of 60
and so this model is
performance of this model is above a
coin flip is above 50
but it's also still very far from being
a perfect classifier
and so now we've trained our model and
so now let's get into the idea of our
fairness assessment
and so when we do our fairness
assessment we want to answer this
question of which groups may be
disproportionately or negatively
impacted by the ai system and in what
ways
the ways we'll go about this assessment
is in four steps
first we want to identify harms so we
want to identify
what kinds of harms are being uh
produced by the system for example
in a system for screening job
applications a qualified app candidates
who are automatically rejected by this
system experience and allocation harm
they are not given this allocation of a
job in a specific tracks transcription
program high error rates might
constitute a quality of service harm and
so times back to our health care
scenario we expect that the patients
that would benefit from this care
management program but are not
recommended for experiences allocation
harm they are not recommended to this
program
and in the context of this
classification stereo this corresponds
to the false negatives
next we want to identify which groups
might be harmed so in most applications
we consider
demographic groups are historically
marginalized such as uh and this could
be based on gender race ethnicity but we
should also consider groups that are
relevant to a particular application for
example when we're talking about speech
text transcriptions we might want to
think about groups based on regional
dialect or whether the speaker is a
native speaker of that language
it is also important to consider the
intersection of groups um
for example um and so
when you're talking about ra oh we have
teachers such as race or we have
features such as gender we want to think
about the intersection of those groups
such as black women latinx non-binary
people etc and so for this context of
this healthcare scenario
uh based on the prior work that we
discussed earlier we're going to be
focusing on race
and next step is to quantify harms
and so we've talked about the kind of
harms that we believe this model uh
this system can produce it will produce
an allocation harm through the means of
false negatives
and so we need to be able to translate
those harms into quantifiable metrics
and so for example in a job screening
scenario that we discuss buzz we might
want to quantify the number of
candidates that are classified as
negative or um but whose true label is
positive and this could also be the
false negative rate fraction
in the context of our healthcare
scenario we want to consider two metrics
for quantifying harms and benefits in
terms of quantifying harms we'll be
looking at the false negative rate this
is the fraction of patients that are
readmitted within 30 days but are not
recommended for this care management
program
and then in terms of benefits we will
look at the selection rate which is the
fraction of patients that are not
recommended that are recommended to this
care management program regardless of
whether they're remitted within 30 days
just being recommended to this program
is considered a benefit and so here the
assumption here is that all benefit all
patients would benefit from this extra
care
and there are
multiple reasons for why we think about
selection rate in addition to the false
negative rate we want to moderate how
the benefits are allocated and we
want to focus specifically on groups
that have been historically marginalized
or disadvantaged
and another
um good reason for including multiple
metrics when we do our fairness
assessment is that gives us a better
sense of robustness about how well our
system is doing or how well our
allocation is because
our measure of readmission within 30
days is a very imperfect measure of this
target that thing we want concerts we
want to target which is who would
benefit most from this carematch program
and so having multiple metrics might
alert us to a large disparities in how
this benefit is allocated
and finally
at the last step of our ferris
assessment we want to quantify those
harms across different groups what we
want to do is focus on this aggregate
and metrics
which is how our our
model performs evaluated on different
demographic groups
or different groups of interest and we
can
summarize those disparities and the
error or model performances by looking
at things such as the difference or the
ratio of those metric values
between the best and the worst
and many cases it might be meaningful to
report the worst performance across all
groups
so for example when if we were talking
about how to report the false negative
rate acro
across rates for our groups we might
summarize our table as the following so
we can see uh on the columns we have our
forward ratio groups and then we have
the false negative rate for each group
then we can see the largest difference
between groups
is 0.24 which would be african-american
minus unknown and ideally this largest
difference would be zero a larger
difference might um signify a larger
disparity
and then finally report the worst case
overall false negative rate which is
0.67
so how do we do the fairness assessment
like this
and within the fair learn package we
provide a data structure called a metric
frame and the metric frame is built on
top of panda's data frame so if you're
used to pandas the metric frame api may
be similar to you and so how we're going
to do this is we're going to instantiate
our metric frame
and assess the uh trained the logistic
regression model we trained above for
potential fairness related harms and how
we instantiate this is we pass in our
metrics of interest we pass in our true
labels for the test data set we pass in
our model predictions and then we pass
in our sensitive features
this creates a metric frame and then by
calling this by group function we can
then see our model's performance uh but
disaggregated by our different racial
groups and so here we can see the false
negative rate for each of our four
racial groups african american caucasian
other and unknown and we can see our
false statement rates of 0.248 for
african-american
0.44 for caucasian .523 for other and
0.67 for unknown
we can also view the disparities by
calling the
difference um by calling functions such
as difference ratio or group max which
shows us the maximal difference between
groups the maximal ratio between groups
and the maximum across all four groups
once again as i mentioned above higher
just a difference it corresponds to more
disparity ideally this difference would
be zero
the ratio sort of also indicates
disparity sort of the ratio of the best
to worse ideally this would be closer to
one
and the maximal across groups just shows
us our worst case overall
and one cool thing about the metric
frame is that if you can pass in
multiple metrics at the same time and so
here we can pass in a dictionary with
three metrics of selection rate false
negative rate and the balance accuracy
score
we can create another metric frame
by passing in the same labels and
predictions and racial groups and you
can see the performance of our model
across all our racial groups according
to all three metrics and so we can see
the selection rate false negative rate
and balance accuracy for all three of
our groups here
and once again we can then call against
a difference and we can see the maximal
difference of our metrics across all
three metrics
and finally since the metric frame is
built on top of pandas data frame we can
also take advantage of the native uh
plotting functionalities of pandas in
order to visualize our model's
performance using the metric frame
so we can use the metric frame
and basically call this uh plot
um plotting function from pandas and
visualize all the performance of our
three different metrics by our racial
groups and so we can generate these
three plots which shows the suction rate
across rates the false negative rate
across our racial groups and the balance
accuracies across our racial groups as
well and the one thing you might notice
is that our various metric the false
negative rate is noticeably higher for
this unknown racial group compared to
some of the others as we mentioned above
the maximal difference um between the
unknown and african-american is about
24-25
and so we can see here that in two parts
that one the selection rate is lower for
the unknown racial group
um that is to mean that the unknown
racial group is uh individuals in this
unknown racial group are less likely to
be selected
and that they also have the highest
false negative rates so they're more
likely to experience this harm
and we observe this disparity even
though we didn't account for race in our
model and there's a variety of reasons
why this may be occur it could be
representational issues such as not
enough data points for each um
group or could just be the future
distribution across groups and in real
world it could be multiple issues it's
often multiple issues at the same time
so now we've done our uh unfairness
assessment we found that our unmet are
our plural our initial model the largest
aggression has this fairness related
harm of high false negative rates for
the unknown racial groups so what can we
do about this
and so at this point we can now talk
about algorithmic mitigation strategies
or strategies for reducing the
unfairness of our machine learning
models
and when we're talking about on um
uh on fairness mitigation these can
occur at multiple points such as the
model training the ai life cycle such as
the task definition or even the data
collection process but when we talk
about these algorithmic mitigation
strategies we're primarily focused on
more so after we are built the model so
we can talk about really three big steps
where
algorithmic mitigations concur one is
pre-processing and so we apply some
mitigation algorithm to the input data
set before it is input in before a
machine learning algorithm is trained on
it so for example some strategies seem
to remove correlations of dependencies
between the input features and the
sensitive features
at time mitigation uh at training time
mitigation strategies in which case we
sort of modify the training process of a
machine learning algorithm sashay tries
to satisfy these various constraints
during the training process and then
post-processing which is after a model's
been trained we apply some thresholding
or um
post-processing of a calibration to the
model such that the model's outputs now
uh
conform to some fairness metric or some
um
fairness of fairness constraint
and in this section we're now going to
dive into two different strategies
one is post-processing and the other is
a reductions approach
so with post-processing
post-processing techniques are a class
of unfairness mitigation strategies that
take in a trained machine learning
algorithm and a data set and apply some
transformation to the outputs of that
machine learning model to satisfy the
fairness constraints
uh these are really maybe the only uh
these may be feasible uh unmitigated
strategies when the developer cannot
directly influence the training of the
model either due to practical security
reasons within fair learn we are going
to use the threshold optimizer um as our
post-processing technique which comes
from this paper heart price and zebra
2016.
and how the threshold optimizer works is
it takes in a prefix possibly prefix
machine learning model we pass in a
constraint such as um
false negative rate parity and then our
objective metric in this case was the
balance accuracy and with the false
negative rate parity we want to aim to
have all our different racial groups to
have the same false negative rate and so
we have our four rational groups and
ideally after calibrating or
thresholding the outputs of these models
all four groups have the same false
negative rate
and so since fairlearn is built on top
of these uh pandas pi data ecosystem
we have an api that's very similar to
scikit-learn so you call the threshold
optimizer you pass in the unmitigated
model you pass in your constraint the
false negative rate parity and we pass
in our objective function which is a
balanced accuracy score
we instantiate the model
and now we can fit the model to training
data and so we fit the training data we
have the training labels and one key
thing about the threshold optimizer is
that we need access to sensitive
features during both training and
testing time so when we call the this
fit function we also need to pass in the
sensitive features as well
and now we've trained our post-process
model we can then call this a predict
function
we pass in the testing data set and we
pass in our testing sensitive features
and we can create another metric frame
on the model
and now let's compare the performance of
our model
compared to our older model and so we
see here that the false negative rate
across uh our newer model the threshold
optimizer is lower across the board for
all racial groups compared to the older
model the unmitigated one our false
negative rate for unknown racial group
has gone down from 0.67 to 0.436 on the
other hand the balance accuracy score
has stayed relatively the same across
all groups
and so what this means
is that we've really been able to reduce
the unfairness of our machine learning
model
without really harming the balanced
accuracy or the performance of our
machine learning model and we can value
um also visualize the maximal
differences of r2 and so we can see here
that the false negative rate difference
between our maximal false negative rate
difference has gone down from 0.24 so 24
down to 6
and we can see that the threshold
optimizer is able to significantly
decrease that false negative rate
disparity and once again we can
visualize the performance of our new
model
next with is the reductions approach
and so with the threshold optimizer
we had took a fairness unaware model and
transformed this output
and so that satisfies our fairness
constraint but one limitation of this
process and that requires access to the
sensitive features during deployment
time
and in this section we'll be talking
about this reduction approach from this
paper agarwal at all
uh which talks about how to obtain a
model that satisfies the fairness
constraint
but does not need access to our sense of
features after the model's been deployed
and the main reductions algorithm in
fair learn is the exponential gradient
algorithm and how this works is that it
takes in a fairness constraint and a
base estimator
and what we do during the training
process is that we'll do this iterative
process where we fit the model to data
we'll see how well we do it in terms of
performance we'll see how well we do in
terms of our ferrous metric and then
we'll re-rate the data data set
and then train a new model on this
we'll keep calculating that performance
metric and the fairest uh constraint
each time
and by doing this iteratively we can
sort of create a final model that sort
of balances this optimizes this
trade-off between the performance
accuracy and the fairness constraint
really well
and since we're training in multiple
models iteratively the model returned by
the exponential gradient actually
consists of several inner models so it's
sort of like a boosting or bagging
algorithm where there's a lot of inner
models behind the scenes wrapped around
by this estimator
and the deployment time the exponential
gradient algorithm randomizes against
these inner models according to the sum
probability weight
and so if we want to instantiate our
exponential gradient model we pass in
two things we pass in our base estimator
and then we pass in our fairness
constraint specified as a special uh
fairlearn object which is a moment
the moment is really just here to help
us do that optimization behind the
scenes easily
and one key thing about exponential
gradient is that the constraints by the
exponential gradient are a bit more
general than the threshold optimizer
whereas the threshold optimizer for
example required the false negative
rates to be equal across groups we can
sort of specify the maximum allowed
difference that we want between the
largest and smallest groups and so when
we instantiate our smashing grading here
we can pass in the constraint as with
this difference brown parameter of 0.02
which basically says we'll allow a small
number of disparity uh between our
different groups so rather than
requiring them all to be equal we'll
allow small
maximal disparity of 0.02
and now
we fit the models of data and since this
model is actually training a lot of
models behind the scenes
it actually takes a bit of a while to
run because it's iteratively training
the model rewriting the data set
creating a new model rewriting data set
and now okay the model is trained and
then we can call the predict function
using this exponential gradient
algorithm and so when we call this
prediction we pass in the testing data
set and one key thing to note is that we
don't have to pass in these sensitive
features like we did for the threshold
optimizer but because the models outputs
are randomized we do pass in a random
state so we can get more deterministic
outputs we call the another metric frame
and we can evaluate our model's
performance
and so we see here that the false
negative rates have gone down it about
the board and that while there is a
decrease in the false negative maximum
false negative rate it's gone down um
0.1
0.15 compared to what it was in the
original model so that the
the unfairness disparity or the increase
in the false negative rate is not
is not as big as it was in the threshold
optimizer but it was bigger than what we
had in the original model at the same
time the balance accuracy score still
stays relatively the same and so one
advantage of this is that yes we didn't
achieve as much as a unfairness
mitigation as we have the threshold
optimizer we didn't have to use a
sensitive feature though so we have a
model that didn't get as much
unfairness reduction but it is more
flexible in how we can use
it and during the training process of
the exponential gradient because it
trains a lot of models behind the scenes
we can actually and it sources those
behind the scenes we can actually look
at those predictors
and we can evaluate how well those
predictors do
and this could be very useful in certain
cases where you're not allowed to apply
uh deploy a randomized algorithm in in
production either due to
legal constraints or other
restrictions you might want to actually
just pull out the best like inner model
and deploy that instead so you have a
deterministic model in production
and so what we'll do here is that we'll
pull out the individual predictors run
them on the
data
and then we can evaluate the performance
of all the models we trained
and so with this graph on the x-axis is
our balanced hour array
and on the y-axis is our false negative
rate difference so balance error rate
represents our model performance the
y-axis represents the false negative
rate difference which is our unfairness
with unbalanced error rate lower bound
unbalanced balance area is better with
false negative rate difference lower
false negative rate difference is better
and so we see here that our on original
models here it has a pretty low balanced
error rate but has a very high false
negative rate difference so it has
pretty good accuracy or is one of the
better models in terms of predictive
performance but has a high false
negative rate difference so a lot of
unfairness
on the other hand the exponential
gradient algorithm and both the
threshold optimizer have relatively the
same balanced error rate if you look at
the scale of this this is 0.02 so more
or less they both have the same
balanced error rate as the unmitigated
model but on the other hand the
unfairness of this
these two models is much lower compared
to original model
so i think this is very important to
highlight because a lot of times when
people talk about unfairness um our this
idea of this fairness accuracy trade-off
that somehow to make our models more
fair we sort of have to make them less
accurate but we see here that we have
cases where we've been able to make our
models a lot more fair we've been able
to reduce the unfairness in our machine
learning model while preserving the
predictive performance
and so now we've covered two different
class techniques for mitigating ferrous
related harms in our machine learning
models compared to this uh
appearance unaware model we trained
earlier and so in this final section
we'll sort of cover about um the we'll
sort of compare the performance of a
model it costs pre-metrics
so one thing we want to look at is how
well does our model do across our
different racial groups according to
some metrics
and so this first graph shows the rate
are four racial categories
african-american caucasian other unknown
and then we can see the false negative
rate for um
all three of our models and we see here
that the false negative rate is
relatively the same across all groups
except the unknown uh racial except for
the unmitigated model the unknown um
the racial group has a much higher false
negative rate on the other hand the
reductions algorithm and the
post-processing algorithm achieve about
the same or even better false negative
rates compared to the unmitigated model
so in this cases these both these models
did successfully manage to either keep
the unfairness uh for each group this uh
the same or even improved upon it
next we want to compare the balance
accuracy for this group and so this ties
back into this idea of like a fairness
accuracy trade-off and that's not really
there what we see is across all
different all the four racial groups
that the balance accuracy stays
relatively the same
across all groups and in the case of the
post-processing model it actually
slightly improves on the unknown racial
group
so in this case once again we see that
overall we've been able to um we've been
able to reduce or keep the unfairness
for each group that are relatively same
while keeping the balance accuracy the
same for all four racial groups
and finally we can look at the overall
performance of our model as well
and we can see overall
that the balance accuracy across all
three models that we train the
unmitigated model the post-processing
model and reductions algorithm is
relatively the same but we can also see
that the on the false negative rate for
our three models is um
higher for the unmitigated model whereas
the post processing and reduction
algorithm
um do slightly better in that case and
so in this case we've been able to
reduce unfairness while keep the overall
predictive performance of the model the
same
and one small caveat is that we want
when we talk about comparing results is
that we want to keep in mind is this
idea of access to sensitive features
um the threshold optimizer requires the
model to have access to sensitive
features during both the training time
and once the model is deployed
if you don't have access to sensitive
features once the model has been
deployed you may not be able to use the
threshold optimizer
the exponential gradient model requires
access to sensor features only during
the training time
and so if you only have access to the
sensitive features in your training data
set or during the model training process
but not today after the model's been
deployed in production you might want to
use the exponential grading algorithm
and so
in this tutorial we discussed um in that
this healthcare scenario through all
stages of the ai life cycle such as the
um
except the model deployment
stage so we talked about how these
fairness related harms can arise around
tax definition when the data is
collected when the model is trained and
how are the models evaluated and we've
also talked about how to evaluate our
assessment model for fairness related
harms according to different metrics
and then we've introduced a variety of
techniques for mitigating any sort of
unfairness that we found but one thing
we want to keep in mind is that fairness
is a socio-technical challenge and yes
we used a software tool fair learn uh to
mitigate these unfairnesses but
mitigation strategies cannot necessarily
be purely technical and they need to be
supported by
best practices and processes such as
government regulation a regulation as
also as organizational incentives
and so one thing i mentioned beginning
is that fairlawn is this open source
project and we're trying to build a
community of practitioners so if you're
interested in learning more about
fairness of ai systems or possibly
contribute to the fair learn project we
recommend um we encourage you to check
out our community and join our community
uh we for further resources can be found
on our website
and so at this time we'll take about 10
15 minutes for questions and then
afterwards we will uh shift to a panel
discussion
uh where michael midday will talk with
three practitioners about how to
incorporate fairness practices
in the real world
there's a question so what's the road
map
so
the road map in one sense
my guess is this is the road map for the
affair learn
mira do you want to take that one yeah
maybe let me
yeah let me make sure i said hello
thanks mario so i'm one of the fair
learned maintainers as is michael madaya
who will be
uh joining um who will be leading the
panel
and i think that when it comes to the to
the fair learn we have a variety of
priorities so it's a community driven
open source project and so uh so largely
the way this works is we'll look for
external contributors like if they come
out of industry out of out of some
out of practice and they they run into a
specific problem they have an idea about
how to start tackling it perhaps they
found it in any any outside literature
um in existing research in their
practice we welcome them to just kind of
suggest them open and issue it and as
long as any of the maintainers is
willing to help them kind of like
take it along uh we are very much open
to that now in terms of what what are
the things that we're currently
prioritizing so so we're open to two
suggestions so i wanted to flag this
first in terms of what it is that we're
currently prioritizing we have some work
happening on developing educational
materials and
developing documentation because we feel
uh based on the various uh various
existing surveys that that very often we
we might be aware of like on the
research side we might be aware of what
the best practices are but there is a
gap between how to translate them into
practice so so so there is a fair amount
of effort around improving documentation
improving
educational materials
now when it comes to technical side of
things we are we're improving like that
the metric frame that they just said
that the minority has been just showing
like to include things like uncertainty
quantification so so being able to more
natively support things like uh
confidence intervals and hypothesis
testing just as as also appear in the
chat so so that that's one area another
area is to support things like rankings
these are applications that come up in
some more of the
kind of standard recommender system
style applications so so we have some
work around that and um
so those are some examples you know i'm
not sure manoj like or maybe even
michael can you can you think of some
some other examples where the current
areas of focus
uh i guess one thing
is we're also thinking about like how do
we tie in fairlearn into responsible ai
documentation practices and so there are
two major ones one is data sheets for
data shifts that i've received data
sheets for data sets i briefly mentioned
another one is called model cards for
model reporting this came out of google
ethical ai team and the idea of the
google um model cars is that can we use
to produce documentation that sort of
highlights and summarizes the
performance of our models across
fairness metrics but also other concerns
as well uh google provides a library
called the model cloud toolkit and so
one thing we want to do is sort of build
on that and integrate that into fair
learn um
and so that way you can train a model
you can produce these reports and they
can easily produce like an html or pdf
document summarizing the performance of
your models in terms of both fairness um
but also other types of constraints as
well if you want to do like regulatory
reporting
i should say that while we're well on
the topic of the fair learner we do have
weekly community calls so on this court
so so there is like i mean there's
variety ways how to get engaged you know
we are always welcome so even if you
don't necessarily have a specific
suggestion of what uh
like like what you would like to
contribute if there is any specific
situation that you that you ran into is
one of the things that we were hoping
that we'll start doing a little bit more
in our weekly community calls so so if
you're facing any real world scenario
where you would like to uh to do to
include fairness assessment or or or
mitigation that we we very much look
forward to
for those kinds of
involvement or just definitely just
reach out
and i can vouch for those community
calls being awesome because i started
coming to those and the next thing i
knew like
i just became really plugged in with
with the team here so it's those things
are great and i think people should
definitely go
the next portion of uh today's session
uh so hi everyone i'm michael madeo i'm
a postdoctoral researcher at microsoft
research uh and i'm very excited to be
judoing today by a fantastic panel uh
hannah and chavani uh would you mind
turning cameras on
uh
wonderful so the way this is going to
work um we'll
first go around i'd love our panelists
introduce themselves
and then i have a couple of prepared
questions to help uh structure the
discussion but it would really love uh
for all the participants uh for you if
you have questions for our amazing
panelists to add those to the chat as
the conversation goes and uh i'll look
for opportunities to surface those
questions and pose those to our
panelists
uh alright so uh fantastic uh let's do a
round of introductions so panelists if
you could uh say your name your uh role
and affiliation and uh just a little bit
about some of your background with uh
responsible ai and fairness in
particular
um uh hannah do you want to go ahead and
get started
sure i'm happy to do that
hey everyone i'm hannah wallock i'm a
partner research manager at microsoft
research new york
and i'm a machine learning researcher by
training um in fact i've been doing
machine learning things for about 20
years now so for a very very long time
but for the past um sort of six or so
years my research has focused on issues
of fairness and transparency as they
relate to ai and machine learning
um i also
do a lot of internal company stuff
within microsoft in the space of
fairness um so i i uh lead microsoft's
internal working group on fairness and
in that capacity end up engaging with a
lot of different product teams from
around the company as they're grappling
with fairness related challenges
thanks
fantastic uh thanks for joining us uh
kristen over to you
hi everyone my name is kristen and i'm a
product pm in cognitive services at
microsoft so we're one of the areas
where we
build and ship
ai systems that range from vision to
decision to language
and i'm part of our responsible ai team
and focus particularly on fairness
much of my earlier work focused on
quality of service across our different
pillars and then i've since transitioned
to focusing more on representational
harms like stereotyping demeaning and
erasure and unfortunate enough to
collaborate closely with many of the
folks on this call
wonderful thanks for joining us uh and
trevaney over to you yeah thanks so much
michael uh hi everyone i'm trevani
gandhi i'm a senior industry data
scientist for life sciences and
responsible ai at data iq
it's a long title um but what that
really means is that i work with clients
to
so i should back up
dataiku is an end-to-end software uh
tool for data science and ai so helping
folks ingest data
clean it make it pretty and then do some
interesting modeling on it plus putting
it into production so we really do the
full gamut
and in my role specifically i'm working
with clients to help them implement best
practices around responsible ai
and as it relates to their broader
issues of maybe governance or oversight
that they're looking for so
i touched sort of the full gamut of
responsible ai but
on the fairness side specifically i have
been working a lot with these fine folks
at fair learn to understand what are the
best practices out there and how to
integrate
packages like fearlearn into dataiku's
system so that anyone can pick it up and
say okay we're going to use this tool or
we're going to use that that method
instead so
wonderful out thanks for joining us
trevani uh yeah and so um let's start
off with a little bit of a higher level
question uh and then we can we can dig
into some specifics so
uh for the panelists could you say a
little bit about
uh how
uh fairness has been incorporated into
your teams and organizations uh
development processes
uh so
uh who would like to start we'll we'll
we'll go around here we want to
take that one first sure i can i can i
can kick us off
um
i think that we we come at the issue
from a very different angle because
we're creating a software
that enables other people to use
and build ai and so for us we're not too
much about like okay
are we being fair in our in our models
because we're not really producing them
um now that said uh we are working
with open source packages internally
also to create better sort of reporting
mechanisms and detection
aspects so we have a lot of interesting
eda tools you can use our fairness model
report also is really
um
is really great because it can
take in a few aspects and say okay based
on everything you've told me here's the
four main
areas of fairness that you should be
looking at and here's how your model
currently stacks up on those uh but from
another perspective you know part of my
work is also on a solution side so i
build
you know sort of prepackaged templates
that we are
passing out to prospects and customers
anyone who wants to pick them up they're
free to use and as part of that we've
implemented a set of checks um to make
sure that okay if you are putting out a
a model that's about predicting
fraud detection or stock alerts or
something have we considered these
aspects of it
so
as we develop more solutions we're
getting it more into that area of doing
it for ourselves but really what we look
at is how do we help other people do
it fantastic uh kristen uh would you
like to to to go next and say a little
bit about uh at a high level how has
china's been incorporated into your
organization's processes
i think there are two main buckets uh
that we like to think about with it
there's the responsible development
bucket which is how we build and ship
the ai that we create and there's the
responsible use bucket which is how can
we enable customers to use it
responsibly including considering
different fairness related issues
so
within that first bucket the responsible
development bucket
we think through which type of fairness
related harms are most likely to apply
to our different systems because
different challenges show up in our
different pillars in the different
products and then think about what are
the priority groups that we want to
prioritize for initially in testing how
are we going to go about assessing any
fairness issues and what does our path
to mitigation look like as well as the
cadence on which we regularly reassess
not just performance to see if any
additional discrepancies have crept back
in but also reassess our fairness
priorities because this is a multi-year
journey and we need to keep going back
and figuring out is there another way
that we need to consider this
within the responsible use bucket
that's where we really get into
promoting uh
disclosing characteristics and
limitations of the service including
types of data it may not have been
trained on so all of our services are on
the pathway to have responsible ai
documentation and transparency notes and
that's where we also will start
promoting resources like fair learning
to customers because the testing that we
do is only part of the story we're a
platform so customers can pick up these
models and use them in so many different
ways that maybe we didn't initially test
for or intend so it's important to
empower them with that knowledge and
start providing tools and resources so
they can assess in their context
fantastic
and there's so many interesting threads
that uh christian are both saying that
would love to to come back to and start
making some connections across in a bit
but i'd love to hear from hannah first
yeah so kristen actually highlighted a
number of things that
unsurprisingly because we both work for
microsoft that i was thinking about
highlighting um michael would it be
appropriate for me to touch a little bit
more on some of the sort of specific
practices
that teams are using when they're when
they're prioritizing fairness
sure that sounds
great
great yeah so there are a number of
things that i've seen teams both at
microsoft and other companies and
organizations use that i think can be
really really helpful when incorporating
fairness considerations into the
development and deployment life cycle
and so running through a few of them in
no particular order so we've seen a rise
in teams undertaking impact assessments
when they're developing their ai systems
so rather than simply launching into
system development and not really
thinking about the the impacts and
especially the potential negative
impacts that their systems might have on
the world we're seeing teams
increasingly conduct impact assessments
before they've really sort of put that
system out into the world so that they
can have a really a better handle on
what those negative impacts might be
in a similar vein we've also seen teams
do sort of pre-mortems so so
anticipating what might go wrong again
you know before a system is actually
deployed in the world and i think both
both of these techniques can be really
useful for getting teams to think about
the impacts that their systems might
have
long before those impacts are actually
realized in in society
um kristin touched on a few things that
i also want to want to highlight
so um when we're thinking about
responsible use things like transparency
notes and fact sheets also model cards
and even data sheets for data sets can
be really useful ways to convey to
people
um
information about what data you know
goes into particular systems or models
the specific performance of particular
models broader sort of performance and
fairness related and other responsible
ai considerations about systems and
stuff like that and i want to note that
the partnership on ai actually has a
project called the about ml project that
is really all about these kinds of
documentation methods and how and what
are some good practices for undertaking
them within different organizations
um
a couple things i also want to mention
just quickly so having responsible
release criteria is also a really good
thing so we often have performance
criteria that we want to hit and other
release criteria but factoring
responsible ai and fairness into those
release criteria is really important um
similarly i've seen some teams undergo
various different responsible ai reviews
before deploying products and i think
that can be really helpful as well
and then once the system is deployed
it's also important to have feedback
channels so it's really really critical
to give people a way to
give
feedback on your systems and to point
out where things might be going wrong
including fairness related things so
i'll pause there but those were just a
few of the of the more specifics just to
sort of round out some of what kristin
was saying about the various ways that
we've seen that we've seen fairness sort
of start to factor into to teams
processes
that's wonderful thank you hannah
and that's a nice segue i think into our
next question i'd love to hear uh from
you all about what are some uh best
practices that you've seen
uh in terms of uh teams adoption of uh
fairness in ai and you know knowing that
all three of you really work across a
range of teams or work with
customers or or clients
would love to hear yeah some some
insights from that uh wide array of
experience on best practices for
fairness and ai what has what has worked
really well uh and what um and you're
thinking about the audience here at pi
data particularly for for data
scientists um
srivani would like would you like to
start us off
yeah for sure um
you know i think that
from a data science scientist
perspective um i don't know if like it's
obvious but
fair learn is a great package and people
should use it and like i don't know what
else to say about that uh you know i
think that there are so many resources
out there now on like how to do this um
from a very like technical perspective
that it's uh it's quite easy for a data
scientist to pick those things up and
say okay this is what
i can i can start using these tools and
there are a lot of like courses on what
is ethics what is responsible ai um and
these things are there but
where i think the real rubber meets the
road bit
is how does that data scientist go out
and like talk to everyone else involved
in the chain
about this
and you know we can't just put all of
the burden on the data scientists so
like the fact that you are here as a
data scientist or a data
coder type or you know one of us uh if
you're here learning that that's great
that's the first step
now how do you go out and talk to people
about it and that's where i think that's
where i'm seeing
more of the like the challenge and a lot
of times what you need to do is
recode it in a way that a business user
that
a product manager that someone who's not
maybe deeply familiar with these issues
is going to understand
and tying it back to governance helps in
that way a lot
i love that
yeah kristen would you like to speak to
this what are some best practices you've
seen what has worked particularly well
i love everything that trovani said
building on that there are a few that
stand out to me um
one is
just helping people take a step back and
learn about fairness including the
differences in fairness related harms
um when
people including executives and various
folks who are going to have input into
our projects
are first starting to think about this
fairness itself can be sort of a
nebulous concept without getting more
concrete i think the term bias can also
cause more confusion because it can
surface in so many different ways
so
getting people to be specific about is
this a quality of service fairness
related issue where it's potentially
performing well for different
demographic groups is it allocating
resources or opportunities differently
or is this showing representational
harms like stereotyping demeaning and
erasure
ends up being a crucial first step
because the ways that we identify
measure and mitigate each one of those
different fairness related issues
is very very different so having that
baseline understanding can help drive
clarity towards what are we prioritizing
and at least understand what might we
need to come back to in the future or
don't understand well enough yet
um
so in addition to getting clarity
i think it's also extremely helpful
particularly when you're dealing with
quality of service related fairness
harms
to
think about it as product quality or
data quality overall so one of the
changes in mindset that we've really
been trying to drive within cog services
is fairness isn't just this standalone
separate thing
this is integrated as part of model
development just like any of our other
quality metrics and the more we can draw
parallels to those existing processes
and attach in the places that make sense
the more traction we've been able to get
with helping people think about it
differently and actually get some of it
to stick
and then the third one that i'll just
wrap up with is
don't rush to mitigate before you
actually understand what it is you're
identifying and if you really understand
how to measure it
because certain mitigations and i'll
just use block list as an easy example
of some stereotyping or demeaning harms
can contribute to erasing
certain sensitive groups and there may
be times where that is the trade-off you
need to make in the short term
but you should at least go into it with
clarity about the limitations of your
approach and what you would ideally like
to achieve
yeah i think that's wonderful and so
could you just say a little bit maybe
for the audience you may not be familiar
with the the term what is a block list
and and how might it be used and uh just
yeah i think to your point of like how
it might uh um unintentionally lead to
potential harms but yeah can you just
give us a little bit more of that
context there
yes uh i think i'll upload a little bit
to just content moderation strategies
generally
so if we take
an email composing system for example
at the point before the model actually
outputs the
text that it's trying to autocomplete
with there might be some sort of
filtering system that could be a list
maybe it's a simple model that checks
is this profanity is this a racial slur
but
depending on
what the model was trained on it may
also be more likely to
censor perfectly neutral text about the
lgbtq community for instance um so
that's more of what i'm
talking through with that piece of
it wonderful thanks uh hannah over to
you are some uh best practices you've
seen and thinking particularly about the
audience here from data scientists or
people working with uh
yeah so we've had so many great
suggestions already these are just all
just so important to think about um a
couple things i want to further
emphasize so
really prioritizing fairness is about
taking kind of a different approach to
development and and it's an approach
that
is more sort of socio-technical than
purely technical but i think it's really
important if we want to actually get
this right and make sure that we are
prioritizing fairness appropriately
um with that in mind one of the biggest
things that stands out to me is not
treating and and you know we've already
touched on these things in several of
these previous answers but not treating
fairness as an afterthought so starting
early thinking about fairness from day
one of development asking questions like
does this data set really capture what i
need it to capture is the way that i've
come up with my with my framing of the
task to be done actually something that
can be achieved with machine learning so
even these kinds of questions very early
on in the process are ways to sort of
prioritize fairness
during that process rather than waiting
until the end in general the teams who
who to and and i'm definitely aware that
prioritizing
can feel like it's slowing down
development but in general the teams
that i see prioritizing fairness sort of
early on and then throughout the
development process
tend to actually have a
better time in the long run i see that
teams who don't think about fairness and
then simply treat it as kind of a final
hoop to jump through before deployment
or perhaps not even think about it at
all run into many many more issues often
issues that can really slow things down
in the long run and that wouldn't have
slowed things down so much had they been
thought about earlier on
one other thing i wanna also touch on
and this sort of relates to kristen's
comment about learning about different
types of fairness um but but it relates
to a few other things as well is
don't be afraid to bring in experts
so we you know if we are data scientists
like me for example i'm a machine
learning researcher it's taken me many
years to get up to speed on fairness
related things on different groups
to people that might be harmed both
within society
and harmed by ai systems in particular
and i still have a massive amount to
learn in any particular engagement when
you're ever developing a single system
it's highly likely that there's
expertise that you will need that isn't
necessarily represented on your on your
immediate sort of technical team and so
i think it's important to recognize that
doing good fairness work often does mean
bringing in people who have really
important expertise but expertise that
isn't typically reflected in the in the
tech circles in which we often run so i
wanted to flag that bit as well because
i i think it's just really important
yeah and to follow up on that plus with
with a question that alfred has asked um
it's a great question so i just wanted
to like get in there uh you know it's
it's funny i think that it's it's it's
hard because people think oh you're
gonna make me slow down you're gonna
make me lose money if i have to build
something fair and there's just like
this false dichotomy that fair means
not good like a bad model roc you see
all this which is like just so not true
right and and
fair learn i don't know why i keep
pitching fair learn i love you guys fair
learning is a good example of that
because you can like check your model
for accuracy and have a balanced metric
i love it um
but the the bigger thing
and this is where again like i go back
to like thinking about the business
users and less of the data scientists
because i think it's easier to convince
a data scientist like this is a tool
that's going to help you
um it's just be like you know
let's look at any major newspaper in the
past month and count the number of ai
related incidents um that have come out
right and like
you can go back in time all the way to
2017 an apple card you can look at like
two months ago with
facebook right like it doesn't stop even
when they know about these things and so
okay maybe it's gonna slow your dev
cycle down a little bit but you're gonna
probably save a lot of money and save a
lot of face to do it up front um and so
i think like that's sort of the language
that that speaks better to two folks out
there um and that's the kind of language
that
we as data scientists have to learn and
kind of like be able to push people into
yeah i think that's such a great point
kristen uh would you like to speak to
this point see this question from alfred
of how do you meet this objection uh
that
incorporating fairness we talked about
integrating fairness into model
development uh how how do you meet this
objection that it might slow down uh
projects
i think that was one great strategy like
emphasizing
look at all of these articles and all
these incidents that are happening like
it shows that this is getting a lot of
attention um
in addition to that piece of it i think
there are some other ways that can help
convince people that this is really
important and as a priority um
looking for research papers or other
things that are at least somewhat
similar to the product or issue that
you're working on there may already be
some existing resources that show
symptoms like this are likely to have
this particular problem um
there's still plenty of research that
needs to be done but there is a growing
body to draw upon
and it can sometimes be easier to open
the door the first crack
when you can point to look at this
research that has already been done
there is a good chance that we have this
problem we're just not looking at it
so that's a great place to start and
even if
it's also really useful i think to just
get an okr or key metric even if it's
just one as a starting point up there
for tracking fairness progress
i think a lot of folks on this call know
how important it is to have different
metrics and just disaggregated
evaluations and that one can just
obscure it
but at least getting something on the
board that places fairness uh at the
same level of priority as the other
quality metrics that we're tracking
even if it's blank for a while it will
be reminding people that this is blank
fantastic so maybe moving from from this
point um i'm curious what uh have you
all seen in your experiences as
potential or as common pitfalls so um
what should the audience hear sort of be
on on the lookout for what might be some
uh common challenges teams run into or
or easy mistakes uh to make
and
who'd like to start this one off
i can start this one hannah yeah go for
it
yeah um gosh
there are a lot of pitfalls um
so
in no particular order so
firstly
thinking that fairness is just sort of a
compliance box to be checked that it's
just sort of a hoop to jump through and
nothing more than kind of an annoying
requirement to kind of deal with on the
way to deploying a system that kind of
attitude tends to lead to really
superficial fairness work that often
doesn't uncover or mitigate the real
issues in a particular product or
service and so i think that's one big
pitfall that i see
another one is thinking that fairness is
something that can be solved
quantitatively now of course metrics are
going to play a role and metrics do
quantify things but that doesn't mean
that it's possible to just solve
fairness for some system or model once
and for all for any group of people and
to declare a system perfectly fair and
yet i do see that attitude coming up
sometimes
um
another pitfall that i've seen is
teams assuming that it's somebody else's
job to think about these things that
there's somebody else who will be able
to come in before deployment and tell
them all the fairness things that are
going wrong and fix the problems for
them and they'll be good to go
at the end of the day fairness as we
were saying before fairness really
should be something that people
prioritize throughout that development
and deployment life cycle but that means
that it's not something that can be sort
of tackled by some some outside party
right before deployment
and then a couple things about
organizations which i think i do want to
quickly flag just because i think
they're important realities to
acknowledge um even though i'm
definitely aware that individuals these
are things that are hard for individual
practitioners to change
so one is that is organizations thinking
that they can suddenly prioritize
fairness throughout their products and
services without hiring sufficient
people with fairness expertise to
support their development teams and this
is a big one that i see i see time and
time again particularly with
organizations rolling out fairness
principles and saying great we have a
fairness principle now well that is
great but upholding that principle is
going to take a bunch of people who have
specific expertise that probably isn't
reflected in your organization already
and on a related note and i've sort of
already half mentioned it organizations
just generally trying to do this work
without investing resources into it so
expecting teams to be able to prioritize
fairness during their development
processes without giving them the
resources to do so isn't going to make
things go smoothly
now that's a really really important
point let's go over to uh travaini for
uh to hear about some
common pitfalls that you've seen in ways
that you've uh worked tried to work
through work around those um we'll hear
from trainee and kristin and then uh uh
we'll go to alfred's question about uh
model governance
great yeah
yeah i think it's interesting um you
know hannah's already hit on a lot of
the main things like you can't fix this
qualitative quantitatively like it's a
much bigger question
i just i'll just tell one story because
like
you know it'll it'll hit home exactly
what what i'm thinking
i was talking to someone who works in a
healthcare
setting and they they build ai in
healthcare
and i said you know so what do you guys
do about the bias and fairness questions
within within your work and i'm really
curious to hear this and this guy's
response was well
we buy like hipaa compliance and all
this we cannot use personal identifying
information in these models
so we're not using demographics we're
not using sex we're not using gender
race whatever
so they're not biased
and i was like not in a position i was
just like it was like a conference or
something i couldn't like actually sit
here and like dig in with this guy and i
was just like
great
and i like kind of just had to walk away
um and i think kind of if uh if i may
like alfred was asking you know what is
it meant by fairness expertise it's not
even expertise it's just like
awareness that oh
things are not going to be fair just
because
we ignore
something like gender or race or we
can like say that oh well it's data and
it's data's true so it's not biased but
like that data was inputted by a human
who's biased um and so
that that's sort of i think one of the
biggest pitfalls is just like
being able to understand that okay
there's going to be problems
um and then on top of that if i
acknowledge yes i know that race is a
problem you know that gender is a
problem how do i find those those
different spots and like proxy variables
are like my the bane of my existence
because i'm constantly trying to cook up
new ways to find a good proxy or like to
assess whether something's a proxy for
race or gender um and so it's like once
you realize it then you realize like how
vast of like a
need there is to understand where these
pitfalls where these like hidden
correlations might be
thanks uh kristen over to you i would
love to hear about some pitfalls you've
seen and some ways that uh you and your
teams have worked around them
yeah
i think a couple a couple to add uh one
is underestimating the complexity of
tackling fairness well and this is where
i think um some of what hannah was
getting at with fairness expertise can
come into play
we're to tackle some of the most
challenging fairness issues that we have
in some at least some of our spaces we
do need folks who have more experience
thinking deeply about fairness
and sometimes we don't have that
experience in-house sometimes it means
we are conducting user research and we
are gathering community input and
experiential expertise in some cases
maybe we need to bring in an external
academic researcher because they happen
to specialize in the particular thing
that we don't have enough knowledge
about to handle with complexity
so i think underestimating complexity is
a big one
assuming the data is good
is another issue because there's a big
distinction between
having enough data to test some of the
top level factors and having sufficient
group representation so i think about a
factor as something like age or sex or
gender identity the thing that you want
to prioritize fairness for but within
that there are different gender
identities there are different age
groups if you're working with a speech
system maybe you're trying to show that
this is fair across different genders
but you also really have to consider
regions across the us what are all of
the different things that could impact
the system and how do you get that
diversity in your data
so that you can actually measure why
things aren't working the way you think
they are
um
and insufficient sample size is another
one
because depending on how you're sampling
you might think your product is doing
great but that's because you just don't
have enough data or you don't have the
right data um and then the final one i
think is just building on what hannah
mentioned waiting until the end it is a
whole lot easier to bake this in from
the beginning
yeah and so much of of what you're
saying resonates with things that i've
seen with working with teams and and
practitioners uh so i wanted to actually
pull uh uh pull into some of the
questions coming in from from chat and
and we have two questions relating uh in
some ways to uh governance and and
oversight of model development and i'm
curious to hear you all speak to
maybe some different models for
um
input
on
uh fairness throughout the model
development whether that's sort of a
top-down more oversight approach or more
bottom-up in um the way that um neus is
is uh asking about um
workers within the company uh advocating
against or fighting against or
organizing against particular uh models
so curious if um uh
you have have thoughts on these
different sort of approaches to
oversight and uh advocacy what that
you've seen might have worked well or um
yeah thoughts on that
yeah so i think i i know for sure that
kristen and hannah are going to have
really great examples of like people out
in the field doing this um
and i i'm again i'm coming at this from
like the
dealing with the average
user who's at a big enterprise right and
who's just like maybe a voice or a
a part of a bigger system
um and and i think that what's really
interesting is here right
last year i i gave a talk and i i i
spoke about how like you have sort of
this overarching executive c-suite sort
of vision of like hey we should be doing
this
okay but we don't know how to do it and
you might have like the ground true
ground ground person data scientist like
myself saying hey have you guys seen the
square learn package it's awesome
but then you need to also have so you
have like this bottom down you have this
top up but you also need like a cross
cutting right you need people like like
kristin and hannah talking to one
another
right you need my team leader and the
business users team leader discussing
this and like
determining the best practices around
what are we trying to do how does that
fit into our bigger question of model
governance our bigger question of
auditing you know accountability
regulations are coming what do we do
right and so
it's not a
uh it's not always so straightforward
but then you know right after i gave
this talk about like you should be a
champion you can like do it ground up
and like find relevant stakeholders
across and everything that was like
right right before to make
meg mitchell were both fired from google
and so then like i i pitched this talk
to someone else and they're like it's a
little weird to pitch it right now
considering such high-profile women were
fired for like being
fire starters or changers um but i i do
think that
um that sort of like ability to find the
right stakeholders
at different levels above you and below
you is really important because that's
going to create the vertical and the
horizontal sort of connections
um
i'll stop there for now because i have
another point but i'll
tell it later
yeah i i i love that i love that idea of
these are horizontal connections ideas
like building a community of practice
and knowledge sharing
as well as some more traditional
organizing efforts uh hannah kristen
thought some on this question
sure um i'll just give a couple of quick
thoughts focused on this sort of idea of
governance um
so firstly within organizations and
companies developing ai systems i think
it's really important to have processes
to have practices in place to make sure
that teams are prioritizing responsible
ai considerations so these might be you
know as we were saying before these
might be um responsible ai reviews that
teams have to go through these might be
things like um some standard that teams
have to adhere to these kinds of things
but these internal processes and
policies so that it's not just each team
for themselves do i prioritize this do i
not prioritize this i think makes a big
difference
um i i also think that the role of
individual advocates you know as as
traveni was saying is just super
important but it's definitely fraught as
we've seen in our research many
practitioners
feel um that they will face costs if
they speak up about responsible ai
either reputation costs or you know
promotion costs these kinds of things
and i think that's a really real uh
consideration that we have to take into
account but it doesn't mean
that individuals working within
organizations shouldn't be speaking up
simply that we need to be very
you know aware we need to be changing
the way organizations function around
individuals to support them in doing so
a couple other things i want to mention
so i do think that the role of external
evaluators or auditors is really
important so to meet gabriel and joy
bollam weenie assess the the performance
of three commercially available gender
classifiers revealing uh performance
disparities particularly involving women
with darker skin tones um this was an
incredibly impactful study that was
taken that took place
um you know by
people who were external to most of the
companies that were being assessed and i
think that's really important we also
saw work from stanford a couple years
ago um where some some researchers
looked at the performance of
speech-to-text apis as well
um i the reason why i think that these
kinds of external audits or evaluations
are so important is that they do create
pressure on organizations to mitigate
those disparities so i think they're an
important part of sort of governance and
accountability within the system
and then regulation definitely plays a
role we're at the beginning of this
journey but we do expect to see
regulation come out within the eu we've
all seen the proposed regulation um we
do expect that this is a space that will
be regulated and increasingly so over
time and i think that that's another
really important way that we can that we
can actually sort of govern and and hold
entities accountable
i love that and and kristen um you know
i i'm curious in in your role within
cognitive services and in particular the
the sort of two
uh aspects of responsibility i develop
and and use or what roles oversight play
and what what have you seen that has has
worked and either of those types of of
top-down bottom-up or more lateral
approaches as as trevini uh discussed
i think in our case what's been
especially effective is having a ship
room so there's a process that teams
have to go through um and then they have
to show up to this meeting where we just
run through what are your results how
are you thinking about this where are
you in your deployment stage
and just having that particular
structure and that thing that they need
to show up for has been really useful
and one of the key value adds that comes
from that is some of the additional
stakeholders who end up joining the room
so it's not just the product team and
not just some cog services folks
necessarily but sometimes people from
other parts of the company join or
people with legal expertise who just
bring a different perspective to it and
have that one thing that they can
converge on
and that practice might also be
something that scales well or skills to
smaller companies as well uh if you just
have a place where you're regularly
meeting and talking through issues
maybe you can just get a fairness
specific one going or if you have
another way where you just run through
your list of how are we doing
with our different ship criteria then
there's a fairness conversation that
happens
i i'd like to just follow up because i
don't realize you're going into the
governance piece this is where i got
really excited about um
and it's funny because i like i'm really
deep in responsible ai bias fairness and
over the course of this year i've gotten
a chance to really integrate with other
parts
of of this conversation um with new
teammates that have come on board and so
governance
and mlaps
and how all of this is like this big
like beautiful mine john nash kind of
thing right where you're like
there's ai governance there's mlops
there's responsible ai
they're not all the same thing but they
all kind of do the same thing how does
this work um and i'm gonna be horrible
and pitch a blog post that i wrote with
my colleagues and i'm gonna put the link
in the chat later but but for us really
there's this idea that
um these are three things that you need
to work together
right you've got governance which is
looking at your entire sort of ai life
cycle right from the beginning all the
way through
um and that that feedback
but then you have a sort of values-based
approach to understanding your ai and
that's where responsibility comes in and
then you have a very like metrics and
sort of monitoring approach that has to
come from mlaps and so
as data scientists you know we say
here's my thing here's my model cool it
goes into production
and we don't really think about it again
uh and mlaps folks which is a growing
area right need to be thinking about it
so what are they looking for well
they're looking to make sure models are
not degrading they're looking to make
sure that
you know data is not drifting that as
their uh pipelines are in production
they're actually complying with other
standards set at the governance side um
so
the work doesn't stop at the this bit of
fairness
um that's what we're focused on right
here you know that's what we as data
scientists might say i'm running these
tests i'm making sure my model is
evaluated in the right way all this
but like like kristin's mentioning with
these bigger review processes
it has to tie up into a bigger picture
and we have to recognize that in order
to create like a more cohesive
pipeline um so i'm going to post the
link in the chat just because i think
it's a great it's a great piece and like
you know i've learned a lot coming from
a pure fairness perspective to now
thinking about okay
how does this like merge into a bigger
picture
i love that i think that that aligns
really nicely with some of the earlier
uh things folks have said about the sort
of ongoing process of monitoring uh
systems in production in deployment and
and in particular even using fair learn
uh to continue to run uh those types of
assessments and and mitigations as one
possible approach uh so for our last few
minutes here before we wrap up at half
past uh the hour uh i'm curious to hear
folks thoughts on
how how have you
prepared or how might you prepare teams
or prepare
practitioners data focus practitioners
to have conversations about fairness and
this has come up across each of the
things that you all have shared kristin
you know you were talking about these
ship rooms and having talking about
about fairness but for many
practitioners particularly folks from
more technical backgrounds they may not
have or feel comfortable having those
conversations and yeah i'm curious on
how do you prepare
the the teams you work with the
individuals you work with to to talk
about fairness whether that's with each
other within their teams to their bosses
or even to external uh clients or
stakeholders
[Music]
um and
kristin do you want to start us off
there
on the spot
i think there's
a particular framework that we use with
teams
that's been useful for just helping them
get on track with understanding what it
is that they're doing and then following
through with it
where the first thing that we'll ask
them to do with their system is
which of these fairness related harms do
you think apply
and it's been really important for
people to
in their own words
discuss why they think quality of
service does or doesn't apply why they
think allocation does or doesn't apply
and why representational harms may or
may not apply
because that's where we start to see a
lot of
learning opportunities and
misconceptions come up that we can start
to correct
and even just going through that step
that you think might be really quick and
simple is a super important foundational
step and then it's like great we have
identified which ones apply
now let's think through
what this means for this system which
groups are we going to prioritize first
and then we'll move on to thinking about
how might we measure this and it's
really just
walking teams step by step through it um
because it can be overwhelming to
encounter it all at once so just that
little bit of structure has been helpful
for
framing the conversation so they can
better incorporate it in their own
products but also use that as a way of
talking about what they're working on
i love that uh trevini uh over to you
how uh do you prepare teams to have
conversations about fairness
yeah um
so okay so i have two kind of
ways to cut up this
i have been a big proponent of fairness
responsible ai in in danaku at my own
company and there are many folks that
are aligned um
but there are more folks aligned now
because i've learned
to
approach the topic in a way that gets
folks to come along um it's really easy
for me to stand in front of people and
be like guess what this is totally
messed up look at this bias racism
sexism and then like people just want to
chew me out because it's
it's a little like unsettling like oh
you're saying i'm racist because this
model's racist or like you're saying
that i'm sexist because this models
so i've had to learn right like this is
a lesson i took of like okay
what am i actually trying to say what i
want to make sure they get out of this
and how do i say it in a way that is
non-content confrontational
which is very much against my nature
believe me um but
i was also firestarter but uh this is
you know
this is one way that like we as
spreaders of this knowledge need to
understand that like
we have to we have to do the work to
make it easier to digest which isn't
great
but whatever it is what it is um and
then the second thing
is that i'm the kind of data scientist
who doesn't believe it till i see it and
i think there's a lot of data scientists
like that
and business users like that um and so
my favorite thing to do is just be like
oh you built this model okay so in
dataiku before we had the model fairness
report i would point them to the
subpopulation analysis i'd be like cool
let's look at the subpop on this
it goes down breaks it down by gender
and we see that oh overall your model
performs at 90
for auc or 90 for recall but when you
break it down by gender it's actually
horrible
for women versus men
um
so
is this actually a good model
and and just like that much like people
are like oh
whoa right and then now you're now
you're talking their language you're
getting you're getting there so like
yeah i think the advice is more for
people who need to go and convince other
people
one don't be confrontational and two
just show it and and they'll they'll see
the light
awesome thanksgiving hannah any uh
last thoughts on on this
yeah i mean i i think we've covered most
of the things that that i that i would
want to say about this um i think
education is really important to make
the space more approachable so the kind
of thing that kristen was saying about
breaking things down into these sort of
more manageable processes and chunks and
helping people understand those in the
context of their of their particular
workflow
um and that i loved what treveny was
saying about really real examples right
to make it actually real and relevant
and and to help teams understand that
this this does happen all over the place
um and then the final thing and again
this this also relates to what treveny
was saying about um not being
confrontational um one of the things
that i often do is i lead with
um a bit of a
discussion about how look this isn't
about bad intentions
systems can behave unfairly for all
kinds of reasons many many reasons and
those reasons seldom include bad
intentions on the part of the developers
and that's a really important starting
point to come from
fantastic well we've covered a lot of
ground here today and i just wanted to
uh thank all of our amazing panelists so
feel free to
put the clap emoji or unmute and clap if
you like
this has been a really wonderful
discussion i know i've learned a lot
from this
everyone else has enjoyed it
and and learned something that they can
take back to their own organizations and
their own work uh managed thank you so
much for your amazing tutorial manager
just dropped a link to the notebook in
the zoom chat and i believe he'll also
share that on the pi data session slack
channel as well
and we encourage everyone to yeah check
out fair learn use it in your work
and uh you know contribute to the
community if you like open issues and
join some of our community discussions
so once again let me thank kristin
hannah and germaine for joining us uh
and thanks everyone for attending
you